like a father figure you know he's just
like a caring father richard was the
last constituent sir david amos spoke to
just minutes before he died on friday i
was meeting him at 11 45 and we agreed
to meet on zoom so he was on zoom
on the wi-fi and i was in my office
ran slightly over to 1202 i think it was
and then
i only find out later that at 1205 this
heinous act happened
i mean
absolutely shocked for the core and i
had sky news on um in the background and
i heard the first reports and i hadn't
even named who it was
but i thought hold on i recognize that
location i think i don't well i thought
i started clearing the worst and it went
every minute it seemed like an hour this
was taken in july this year it was a
joint party the two shared a passion for
getting more young people involved in
politics and had become good friends
they were due to meet again in a few
days
the thing that really captured him
he really ran with was this children's
parliament idea and
he made it his we talked a month so ago
about how wonderful it would be if the
adult
speak for the house was to be engaged
with us and he was going to ask lindsey
hoyle
a video message for the kids and also a
photo with the head teacher champion the
disbelief that the loss of this much
respected man is shared across this town
but for sir david's friends it's
all-consuming
sally had been a close confidant for
more than 20 years i feel absolutely
devastated because on a personal level
he was always there for me he's left a
massive hole in south and in my life as
well because
i loved him dearly and um
i don't think it's really sunk in that
he's not i'm never going to see him
again but fortunately i've got so many
precious memories that
the memories will have to sustain
sir david felt like a friend to lola too
as well as an inspiration she'd met the
mp a number of times as the children's
parliament representative for the local
area
a legacy that perhaps leaves a glimmer
of hope for the future of south end but
many won't forget their neighbor their
mp
but most of all
their friend ash narang sky news in
lyonsi